[Musique]
cette saison la plupart des institutions
adressent leurs voeux à leurs membres
salariés sympathisants des moments
d'échangés de convivialité où l'on fait
le point un bilan d'étape c'était le cas
ces derniers temps avec le service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
bonjour belfort birota bonjour monsieur
viol tombe bonjour les auditeurs la
martinique 1ère et bonne année à vous
tous et et avoue tout président peut se
disent merci d'être d'ancrer dans son
caddie le sedee sont deux mots belfort
birota c'est un budget de près de 30
millions d'euros pas loin de 1500
personnes est réparti sur l'île et se
trouve que vous venez de présenter de
nouveaux personnels qui viennent d'être
recrutés avec des accusations de
favoritisme qui ont circus et qui ont
circulé par ci par là on parle de jeu
piper lors du concours de piston pour
des proches de l'encadrement ou de leurs
amis
dites nous tout ce matin belfort birota
bien mais je crois que les réseaux
sociaux du bon et du mauvais aujourd'hui
nous avons pu voir que nous certains
certaines personnes mal intentionnées
ont voulu semer le trouble dans notre ce
disque nous essayons de rodez c'est tout
ce qui a été fait l'a été selon la loi
selon les textes en vigueur
il y a eu un point me concours pourra
coûter 18 sapeurs pompiers
professionnels
mais là le décret du toit l'article 3 du
décret du 24 avril 2012 permet au
président selon sa discrétion son
pouvoir discrétionnaire de nous écouter
dans le cadre de ce qu'ils appellent
ainsi ou deux c'est à dire la moitié de
18,9 sapeurs-pompiers sous des critères
qui n'a pas à publier puisque c'est son
rêve
comprenez que dans une dans un petit
pays comme le nôtre on va trouver des
liens de parenté avec vous tout cas une
chose est sûre j'invite les uns les
autres au regard de la liste heures il
n'y a aucun birota il n'ya pas mes
enfants
mérignac rami rod enfants c'est ce qui
est ce qu'on va laisser les amis de
bureau nous avons tous des
dans ce pays nous sommes plus de trois
cent cinquante six mille maintenant
puisque la population a baissé tout le
monde se connaît c'est un faux procès
qu'on vous fait c'est un sens poussé
comme un fait mais je suis quand même je
suis pas là je ne suis pas dans cette
démarche je suis plus dans une démarche
d'éducation des gens d'éducation des
jeunes qui ont mal utilisé les réseaux
sociaux
alors justement vous avez pendant votre
discours avant-hier à l'institut
martiniquais du sport à l'occasion de
ses voeux faisait quand même fustige un
certain nombre d'attitudes qui selon
vous qu'il faudra gommer vous avez
évoqué la loyauté les précautions à
révoquer les précautions à prendre sur
les réseaux sociaux et vous demandez à
vos troupes de ne pas scier la branche
sur laquelle ils sont assises cesser ses
troupes s'étaient lien cette affaire de
recrutement
s'étonna simple parce qu'il faut savoir
que l'intrus avait reçu arrive à la
prise de distance nous étions dans un
état financier des plus rap il y avait
un déficit de 3 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire que l'ancien gouverneur je
ne jette la pierre à personne à 20 da
vais pas gérer de manière rigoureuse et
les sommes allouées par l'état dans le
cadre dans le cadre du plan séisme
antilles puis deux puis trois millions
deux ont été consommés au fonctionnement
salle se divertir grâce à l'apport
l'augmentation de la contribution du pc
les trois millions d'euros nous serions
encore dans le rouge aujourd'hui et je
dois ce je dois également dire que sans
l'effort consenti par les maires qui ont
compris vu la manière de ne fonctionner
et vu les projets que nous avons vu les
aides que nous apportons et
l'accompagnement que nous apportons au
maire ils ont compris qu'il faut payer
les contributions aujourd'hui au moment
où je vous parle
tous les maires ont joué le jeu ce qui
fait que je peux dire puisque j'ai voté
le 27
le mois dernier le budget du sdiss nous
sommes état à 32 millions d'euros soit à
peu près de 10% d'augmentation c'est à
dire qu'il ya plus de mauvais élève de
la classe parmi ces mères qui ne versait
pas lent et assurant des maires
responsables qui ont compris le sens de
l'action que vous menez c'est à dire
doter notre pays d'un service des
rosiers de sans exception sans exception
de service départemental
et dès ce lundi deux de haut niveau
service qui sera de par la volonté du pc
transformer prochainement service
territorial d'incendié et de secours de
pc le président du conseil exécutif
alors vos prédécesseurs les personnels
tous dénoncent l état de délabrement des
saisines et des infrastructures un
moment alors cette année plusieurs
chantiers ont été là il ya une nouvelle
caserne aux trois ilets au lamentin et
qui vient d'être inaugurée universal et
ce sera bientôt le cas d'autres
chantiers vont arriver très vite qu'à ce
pilote voeckler basse pointe donc c'est
vraiment renouveau pour le dix septième
art nouveau et c'est une démarche nous
allons dans une démarche d'humanisation
des des casernes et de création
d'occasions tout neuf c'est vrai que
comme vous l'avez dit nous en avons déjà
livré toi il y a trois autres ils vont
sortir de terre où tout est rôdé travaux
promotion 2010 leurs dix autres elle a
lancé d'ailleurs qu'à ce pilote comme
vous l'avez dit voeckler et bassecourt
et nous allons poursuivre par la suite
je vais pouvoir de l'investissement
puisqu'au moment je vous parle le
financement des casernements et et
bloqué des et déjà abouti
nous sommes quand même dans la suite de
l'action de votre prédécesseur et 7
rebonds mariette non eh bien vous savez
la boetie c'est une continuité et une
continuité et moi je suis pas de ceux
qui parce que mon prédécesseur a fait
tout mal il a comme tout à chacun comme
il désire je ne commettrai peut-être
également mais j'essaie laisse pas de
faire de mon mieux pour doter notre pays
de se disent le qualité alors quelle est
l'action de belfort birota dans sa
mandature à la présidence du sne ici
l'accent que vous mettez sur qu'on
s'appelle le tam le traitement de
l'alerté martinique et à sa mère il y à
aussi au niveau interne heures aller
vers ce que j'appelle la pèce bât c'est
à dire que mettre en place un dialogue
social de qualité et je remercie les
syndicats qui ont accepté de jouer à
fond ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on se
dise le calme semble être revenu ce qui
nous permet de continuer notre marche en
avant et la dossier le contraire belfort
birota si c'était le cas la 2g leur
lança en et atlas moment c'est celui
traitement de la leyre
a été financé aussi par la cdm à 2
millions d'euros j'ai beau vous dire que
cet outil va nous permettre de gagner du
temps au niveau de l'intervention auprès
oui c'est exactement c'est quoi c'est de
vous avez lorsqu'on appelle pour qu'on
fait le 18 de sa rive le ctad couach
transmet la pelle dans les sentes et à
ce moment les synthés hagen alors pour
les traitements automatisés cela se fera
uniquement par les nouveaux moyens
techniques informatiques cdu veut dire
qu'ils vont recevoir directement de
chacun dans la caserne la plus proche du
lieu d'intervention
une affiche et on l'espère gagne ainsi 2
ou 3 minutes parce que vous savez de
trois minutes sa côte d'azur pour la vie
et dans la rue mais ça peut sauver
quelqu'un l'image du sapeur pompier en
martinique
est ce que vous vous penchez sur cette
question tout à fait parce que comme je
dis comme je le dis souvent aux
sapeurs-pompiers nous devons servir
d'exemple à ce moment là haut mais
repenti qu'on me dise pas oui au moment
où toutes les valeurs partagées l'eau au
moment où il ya plus d'autorité nous
sommes la structure la seule structure
capable de servir de repère à la
jeunesse pourquoi j'exige de mes impôts
pompiers qui sera exemplaire dans la
retenue dans leurs propos et de laure
manaudou
même dans la vie civile message reçu 5
pour un 5 sur 5 eme somme jusqu'à
maintenant je n'ai pas eu de
l'observation particulier rafa qui que
ce soit est ce que vous allez multiplier
ce que vous avez les moyens de
multiplier par exemple toutes ces
formations dispensées auprès des jeunes
vous savez que dès que dès qu'il y avait
un moment on disait ben et vous formez
votre enfant aux premiers gestes de
secours
il ya des rushes et puis souvent on
entend dire il y a plus place à joe cas
c'est notre ambition
je peux vous dire que la jeunesse
martiniquaise les pros parfaitement un
autre à nos appels puisque c'est tous
les jours que les jeunes d'une c'est ce
que dalle et simple de ce que pourrait
être engagée comme sapeur pompier
volontaire
c'est également les jeunes de 13 jusqu'à
18 heures qui viennent c'est ce que au
bout est que pouvait partir de ce qu'on
appelle les jeunes sapeurs pompiers
il reste très peu de temps l'état dans
tout ça l'état qui souvent accusés de
confier de nouvelles tâches de plus
exigeants et puis qui ne tend pas la
main financièrement notamment est ce que
l'état joue le jeu avec gaza l'état que
nous avons pu mettre en place
ce programme de construction de casernes
puisque l'état nous verse 50% dans le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle le plan séisme
antilles justement je profite de
l'occasion pour monsieur m le préfet
parce que il nous accompagne sur ces
dossiers la dernière question 1500
professionnels du feu avec des
volontaires également est-ce que c'est
assez pour notre personnel administratif
également qu'il faut pas négliger
puisque il ya à peu près 80 personnes
qui s'occupent de l'administration est
ce que ca c est dans un bon état pour
eux se disent de notre dimension pour
une population d'1 mo cadre de carson
mais les personnes je crois que cela est
suffisant
il suffit simplement que nous puissions
affiner notre organisation et nous
serons qu'à performant ce que j'espère
merci belfort birota président du
service départemental d'incendié de
seconde en ferrari
le groupe y est toutes les fois où janot
a besoin merci votre service
[Musique]